wie runter mit dem co2 union und spd
kommen einem kompromiss in der
klimapolitik näher
wie lernt eine maschine für seine
forschungen zu künstlicher intelligenz
wird ein tübinger informatiker
ausgezeichnet dramatische tage an
spaniens mittelmeer küste die heftigen
unwetter lassen nicht nach
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg genannt und ein
herzliches willkommen an diesem
freitagabend norbert lehmann ist auch
dabei für den sport an gut mit unserer
familie
der countdown läuft in einer woche will
die bundesregierung ihr groß
angekündigtes programm gegen die
erderwärmung präsentieren zur stunde
berät die koalitionsspitzen im
kanzleramt
das ziel ist klar bis 2030 soll der co2
ausstoß um 55 prozent gesenkt werden im
vergleich zu 1990 in vielen sind sich
union und spd schon einig bus und bahn
wollen sie fördern auch e mobilität und
fahrradwege
strittig war bislang vor allem noch die
entscheidende frage wie der verbrauch
von diesel benzin heizöl und erdgas
teurer gemacht werden soll
und da deutet sich jetzt ein kompromiss
anlass bohnsack ihnen die
klimaverhandlungen der
regierungsparteien kommt offenbar
bewegung die umweltministerin spricht
sich zwar für einen fairen preis für co2
ausstoß aus beharrt aber nicht mehr auf
einer steuer
ich will jetzt nicht einzelne maßnahmen
daraus bewährten mir ist wichtig dass
wir das ziel am ende erreichen das ist
das was uns gelingen muss wir müssen am
ende co2 reduzieren müssen unsere
hausaufgaben das pack dem was mir in
deutschland übernommen habe er wirklich
auch erfüllen und damit zeichnet sich ab
dass das umwelt schädliche kohlendioxid
über den handel mit zertifikaten
bepreist werden soll
als einer von vielen schritten wir
müssen die bürger mitnehmen
wir müssen klimaschutz zum projekt für
alle machen tun wäre sinnvoll dass wir
die anreize bei energetischer sanierung
bei umstellung auf neue motoren
beispielsweise auch bei heizungen dass
wir das starten und dann begleiten mit
dem zertifikatehandel dann glaube ich
haben wir 2030 den größten effekt allein
das umweltministerium weist auf seiner
homepage dutzende maßnahmen zur
schadstoffreduzierung aus dennoch haben
die grünen zweifeln um eine große sorge
ist dass das klimapaket nicht einmal
ansatzweise den großen problemen
angemessen ausfällt denn das klimapaket
muss die größe haben die das ausmaß der
klimakrise entspricht vor wenigen
minuten sind die spitzen der koalition
im kanzleramt
islam zusammen gekommen um noch einmal
über alle maßnahmen zu beraten
die zeit drängt in genau einer woche
will die bundesregierung ein
gesetzespaket vorstellen mit dem
deutschland seine klimaziele doch noch
einhalten kann also der ausstoß von co2
wird teurer durch einen handel mit
verschmutzungsrechten oder durch eine
steuer was der unterschied es zeigt
volker doccheck das co2 steuer modell
der spd möchte den ausstoß des
treibhausgases über den preis steuern
der gedanke
je teurer zum beispiel das benzin desto
weniger wird verbraucht mit einer
jährlichen thema prämie soll der staat
die verbraucher entschädigen zb mit 80
euro pro kopf für viel co2 freigesetzt
wird allerdings draufzahlen
die union stellt die lenkungswirkung
durch den preis in frage und setzt auf
den nationalen zertifikatehandel sie
will dass eine obergrenze beim
kohlendioxid ausstoß festgelegt wird und
nicht überschritten werden darf
die industrie zum beispiel
mineralölkonzerne muss dafür rechte
kaufen die zahl der zertifikate und
damit die menge des co2 ausstoßes soll
jahr für jahr reduziert werden
die kosten für die zertifikate gibt die
industrie an den endverbraucher weiter
eines ist sicher bei beiden modellen
wird der am ende mehr bezahlen als
vorher
ja wir schauen auch nach berlin gunther
love energy ist vor dem kanzleramt wo
die koalitionsspitzen beraten chuck
unter la verna gerade entscheidende
weichen gestellt
also zumindest geht es jetzt hier
tatsächlich in die endrunde obwohl es
natürlich noch viele offene fragen gibt
über einige von denen die
koalitionsrunde hier hinter mir heute
auch beraten wird zum beispiel über die
frage wie viel soll der klimaschutz am
ende kosten oder welches ministerium
soll wie viel co2 in seinem bereich
einsparen da gibt es durchaus noch
unstimmigkeiten hinter den kulissen so
streiten sich zum beispiel das
verkehrsministerium und das
umweltministerium über die frage ob die
vorschläge von verkehrsminister scheuer
ausreichen man sieht also auf den
letzten metern will hier bei diesem
kompromiss keiner zu schnell bei geben
trotzdem zeichnen sich schon konturen ab
wir haben heute ein papier einsehen
können das intern in der cdu schon
verteilt worden ist darüber will die cdu
am montag beraten und es vielleicht auch
beschließen
gibt es konkrete maßnahmen unter vielen
anderen auch die dass die
flugverkehrssteuer deutlich drauf gehen
soll
damit flüge vor allem inlandsflüge
teurer werden also da gibt es viel zu
tun viele kleine zwischenstationen auf
dem weg zum klima kompromiss die
koalitionsrunde kann heute hier darüber
beraten wie sie das in den nächsten
sieben tagen meistern möchte die
abgenommen freitag nächster woche sollen
erst dann wissen vielen dank und energy
nach berlin
auch im koalitionsstreit um die
grundrente gibt es offenbar bewegung in
der haushaltsdebatte des bundestags
sagte arbeitsminister heim
er sei bereit über die zielgenauigkeit
der leistung zu reden also darüber wer
den zuschlag auf geringe renten bekommen
soll
die union fordert seit langem die
bedürftigkeit der betroffenen zu
überprüfen
die spd hat das bisher abgelehnt ist die
afg eine bürgerliche partei ja sagt
parteichef bauland und hat viel
widerspruch geerntet jetzt auch vom
bundespräsidenten der sich in einer
bürgerlichen tradition sehe können nicht
gleichzeitig einem ausgrenzenden
autoritären oder gar völkischen denken
huldigen sagte frank walter steinmeier
im spiegel
jede partei müsse für sich entscheiden
wo sie stehen wolle
entweder völkisch kollektivistisch oder
aufgeklärt bürgerlich afg chef bauland
hat steinmeier daraufhin mangelnde
neutralität vorgeworfen
der rückzug von bernhard mattes als
cheflobbyist der autoindustrie zeigt die
verunsicherung der branche
die internationale automobil ausstellung
in frankfurt wirkt wie ein schatten
ihrer selbst die stände deutlich kleiner
viele hersteller sind erst gar nicht
gekommen
der schutz des klimas forderte autos
verdient wird aber mit suvs dieses
dilemma muss deutschlands
schlüsselindustrie lösen
isabel de la vega er versucht das alles
so normal wie möglich wirkt als hätte er
nicht gestern das handtuch geworfen
bernhard mattes der mächtige chef des
verbandes der automobilindustrie und
gastgeber der iaa
gestern noch hatte er die
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel über die
messe geführt und dann seinen rücktritt
zum ende des jahres erklärt warum er das
ausgerechnet während der tat dazu wollte
man es auch heute nichts sagen
offenbar standen nicht alle konzernchef
center mattes als oberstem auto
lobbyisten sein stellvertreter stellt
klar an den zulieferern lag es nicht
natürlich ist nicht schön den einzelnen
wieder raus sprechen
wir haben uns das ab so liefere
überhaupt nicht gewünscht wir
unterstützung der matte stehe aber wir
können die diskussionen bei dem
hersteller natürlich auch nicht
kontrollieren als habe die branche nicht
genug probleme
der diesel skandal hängt noch nach und
auf der iaa geht es um einen gewaltigen
umbau der branche zur elektromobilität
eine milliardeninvestition die nicht nur
gestemmt werden muss sondern offenbar
auch für streit zwischen den herstellern
sorgt der vw-chef habe dabei die anderen
hersteller überrumpelt ja dies hat ich
glaube es war im januar gesagt wir
machen nur elektro wir wollen keine
brennstoffzelle wir wollen keine hybride
und das hat den anderen deutschen
herstellern nicht so gut gefallen glaube
ich und daher kommt dieser ganze druck
im vga auch von außen steht die branche
stark in der kritik gegen autos als
symbol der umweltverschmutzung wird
während der iaa immer wieder
demonstriert nach paris dort ist der
verkehr schon an normalen tagen eine
echte herausforderung heute erst recht
beim die beschäftigten der
nahverkehrsbetriebe streiken gegen die
rentenpläne der regierung bislang
durften die banner relativ früh in rente
im schnitt mit mitte 50 doch das will
präsident makro ändern
aus paris tours weiter wer heute in
paris zur arbeit wollte hatte ein
problem die meisten busse und züge
fielen aus doch die reaktion der
fahrgäste überraschend wohlwollend
das ist nicht toll für mich aber ich
verstehe warum die leute das machen
ich verstehe dass wenn man mal etwas
erreicht hat dann kämpft man auf uns zu
behalten
die gewerkschaften hatten zum streik
aufgerufen heute gehen bahnbeschäftigte
im durchschnitt die 750 jahren in rente
die regierung will das ändern deren
reformen würden die beschäftigten fast
ein drittel ihrer rentenkosten sagen
gewerkschafter der bahn sind als erster
mobilisiert aber wir hoffen dass bald
alle arbeiter des landes hinter uns
stehen
premierminister phillipe wir nun beides
seien standfest und beweglich in der
tram ihn als unsere entschlossenheit ist
groß aber die reform ist ja noch nicht
zu ende geschrieben wir brauchen die
beteiligung aller der halter sorge nach
die abgeflauten proteste der gelb westen
könnten wieder aufflackern
die regierung verspricht nun
vorsichtshalber bürgeranhörungen wenn
man etwas aufgegeben hat dann ist es das
tempo aber der wille ist immer noch
intakt die reformen voranzubringen
das ist das bild das präsident makro
jetzt von sich präsentiert er hört zu
für nächste woche haben gleichwohl
weitere berufsgruppen protest
angekündigt
der job hat es in sich viele reisen
mörderische arbeitszeiten jedes wort auf
die goldwaage gelegt die us-demokraten
suchen einen kandidaten oder eine
kandidatin jemanden der präsident donald
trump bei der wahl im nächsten jahr
schlagen kann
gestern war fernsehdebatte und die
favoriten schälen sich langsam heraus
ein ex vizepräsident und zwei vom linken
flügel alle um die 70 peter jäger hat
zugeschaut tv-debatten scheinen
grundsätzlich nicht sein ding zu sein
doch beim dritten versuch in houston
texas läuft es besser joe biden wirkt
auf der bühne insgesamt ausgeruhter
angriffslustiger als bei den beiden
debatten zuvor zum beispiel als es um
seinen plan für das gesundheitssystem
geht wo der einzelne person die krebs
oder
ihre schwere krankheiten hat wird
automatisch in dieses neue system kommen
sie werden deshalb nicht pleite gehen
wirklich begeistern kann beiden aber
auch dieses mal nicht in fast allen
umfragen ist er weiter spitzenreiter
doch einige demokraten fürchten mit 76
jahren könnte er den präsidenten amt
nicht mehr gewachsen
wir haben einen schwierigen punkt
erreicht denn viele machen sich gedanken
darum ob joe biden den ball nehmen und
ohne zu straucheln über die ziellinie
bringen kann beiden in der debatte
zwischen bernie sanders und elisabeth
die beiden gelten als linksausleger
fordern etwa eine radikale reform des
gesundheitssystems senders heiser und
zeitweise überraschend grantig wollen
droht ihn mit klare rhetorik zu
überholen
sie will wie alle anderen schärfere
waffengesetze
das ist schlicht und einfach korruption
wir haben einen kongress der von der
waffenlobby in geiselhaft genommen wird
diese debatte hat noch mal klar gemacht
dass ein trio das feld anführt joe biden
elisabeth geboren und bernie sanders und
das war von der ersten minute an klappt
das bewerberfeld ist nun auf zehn
kandidaten geschrumpft ihre wichtigste
botschaft in houston aber war eine
gemeinsame trump muss raus aus dem
weißen haus
wir stecken mitten in einer dritten
industriellen revolution da ist sich
bernhard schölkopf sicher für seine
bahnbrechenden erkenntnisse bei der
entwicklung künstlicher intelligenz hat
der tübinger wissenschaftler jetzt den
renommierten körber preis bekommen
dotiert mit einer millionen euro
christina cuts über den mann der
maschinen das lernen wert es ist eine
besondere beziehung zwischen mensch und
maschine und sie verändert sich in
ungeahnter weise maschinen werden immer
autonomer und intelligenter aber was
genau ist eigentlich intelligenz das ist
die große frage die über der forschung
von bernhard schölkopf steht für mich
ist es eines der größten ungelösten
probleme der wissenschaft dass mir
funktioniert intelligenz wie nehmen wir
die welt war
der strukturen in der welt wie können
wir dinge vorhersagen schölkopf
entwickelt verfahren die es maschinen
ermöglichen aus erfahrungen zu lernen
könnten sie irgendwann klüger werden als
menschen
um diese frage ging es auch bei der
verleihung des körber preises heute in
hamburg
künstliche intelligenz im verbund mit
big data kann heute schon vieles das
schürt hoffnung und es weckt ängste die
einen glauben dass sie mit neuen
mensch-maschine verbindungen eine neue
stufe der evolution erreichen die
anderen glauben dass irgendwann
intelligente supercomputer die macht
übernehmen bernhard schölkopf kann diese
befürchtungen verstehen aber erteilt sie
nicht ihn faszinieren lernende maschinen
sie müssten nicht programmiert sondern
trainiert werden sowie menschen weil
auch ein menschliches gehirn natürlich
nicht von irgendjemanden programmiert
worden ist das heißt die beispiele an
intelligenz die wir sehen menschen und
tiere sind nicht programmiert sondern
sie werden durch erfahrung trainiert
gerade in der medizin ruhen große
hoffnungen auf den neuen klugen
maschinen
sie werden unser leben verändern so viel
ist sicher was genau er mit ihnen
anfangen liegt in unserer hand
und wo wir gerade beim lernen sind
wissen sie wir heute 100 jähriges
jubiläum feiert die grundschule die
große idee dahinter ein ort für alle zum
lernen egal ob arm oder reich ein
schritt zur chancengleichheit der
erstmals 1919 in der weimarer verfassung
verankert wurde
zitat auf einer für alle gemeinsamen
grundschule baut sich das mittlere und
höhere schulen wesen auf stefan
schlosser blick zurück und nach vorn
englischunterricht in einer deutschen
grundschule
das gesicht auf
[Musik]
gemeinsam lernen jungen und mädchen alle
konfessionen kinder aus armen und aus
reichen elternhäusern erst mit
einführung der grundschule und der
allgemeinen schulpflicht vor 100 jahren
wurde das möglich eine revolution in der
schulpolitik standesunterschiede
überwinden den gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt fördern und mehr
gerechtigkeit im bildungswesen beim
festakt in der frankfurter paulskirche
würdigt bundespräsident frank walter
steinmeier die grundschule als eine der
großen demokratischen errungenschaften
doch man sei noch nicht am ziel
auch 100 jahre nach der gründung der
grundschule in der weimarer republik
geht es in deutschland noch immer darum
chancengerechtigkeit zu verwirklichen
noch immer hängt bildungserfolg in
unserem lande zu stark von sozialer
herkunft ab es braucht auch mehr gut
ausgebildete lehrer bessere ausstattung
und bezahlung anders sein die aufgaben
mit integration und inklusion nicht zu
leisten
manche experten sprechen von einer neuen
bildungskatastrophe weil gerade im
grundschulbereich hoher lehrermangel
besteht sehr viele quereinsteigerinnen
und quereinsteiger zum einsatz kommen
die grundschule ist eine
erfolgsgeschichte aber sie steht vor
großen herausforderungen will sie ihr
ziel behalten bestmögliche ausbildung
für alle von anfang an
es sind bilder die man aus den trockenen
sonnenverwöhnten gebieten im süden
spaniens so gar nicht kennt bis zum
horizont riesige wasserflächen
entstanden durch massive unwetter
mindestens vier menschen starben fast
jeder ort in der region um valencia und
murcia ist irgendwie betroffen und am
wochenende soll es weiter regnen
tobias häfner berichtet
ohne boot gab es auf dieser
schnellstraße kein entkommen für
eingeschlossene autofahrer starkregen
hat die tunnelröhren fast komplett
gefüllt ob es unter wasser opfer gibt
die es nicht wie er zurück ans ufer
geschafft haben ist offen
die feuerwehr taucher durchsuchen da
unten ein umgekipptes fahrzeug da könnte
jemand drin sein
aber ich weiß es nicht um solche
suchaktionen möglichst zu verhindern
gilt eine eindringliche warnung der
behörden lasst eure autos stehen die
menschen in lausanne cassar es neben
eigentlich am wasser doch manche nun
sogar mittendrin nicht weit entfernt von
den mittelmeerstränden schiebt sich
braunes regenwasser durch die straßen
und der blick in richtung himmel
verspricht kaum besserung dauerregen und
starke gewitter werden auch das
wochenende dominieren das ungewöhnliche
unwetter gebilde dreht sich konstant
über dem südosten spaniens 200 liter
regen pro quadratmeter in 24 stunden 120
alleine in den letzten sechs stunden so
was gibt's nur alle 100 jahre sagen wir
die wetterexperten etwas treibgut dann
richtig viel treibgut und bald wird die
nächste brücke so unfreiwillig zum
staudamm eilig er beorderte bagger und
lastwagen versuchen das nötigste zu
beseitigen
der katastrophenschutz kommt kaum zur
ruhe
oberste priorität hat die suche nach
vermissten erst danach kann das
riesenprojekt aufräumen so richtig
beginnen zum sport kein guter tag für
die deutschen volleyballer noch klarer
zu sagen klarer fehlstart der mit hohen
ambitionen angetretene vize
europameister unterlag im topspiel der
vorrundengruppe b gegen den er im
dritten serbien klar mit 0 zu 3 und
lieferte eine insgesamt ernüchternde
vorstellung ab wenn nur selten kann die
deutsche mannschaft gegen starke serben
ihr durchsetzungsvermögen wie hier beim
schmetterschlag von christian fromm
zeigen die deutsche auswahl liegt
ansonsten im gesamten spiel nur im
rückstand
die miene von trainer andre adjani
verfinstert sich zunehmend nachdem auch
der zweite satz
die serbien geht ein aufbäumen ist aber
danach kaum zu erkennen stattdessen
spürbare verunsicherung die deutschen
medaillenhoffnungen bekommen mit dieser
klaren 0 2-auftaktniederlage gegen einen
der mitfavoriten gleich zu turnierbeginn
einen deutlichen dämpfer
altmeister spanien und außenseiter
argentinien kämpfen im
überraschungsfinale der basketball wm um
die nachfolge des gestürzten
titelverteidiger usa 80 zur 66 hieß es
am ende des halbfinals der südamerikaner
gegen frankreich das ja zuvor die usa
bezwungen hatte und heute enttäuschte
spieler des tages luis scola der 39
jährige argentinier der dominierte mit
28 punkten und 13 bars und morgen abend
das bundesliga-topspiel rb leipzig gegen
bayern münchen und das ist natürlich
auch das duell zweier top trainer
nagelsmann gegen kovac vor dem spiel
sind erstmal die trainer gefordert als
wortakrobaten in den pressekonferenzen
ein ausdruck vor allem bleibt hängen und
es wird ein abnutzungskampf dann wird es
immer auch ein abnutzungskampf man kennt
sich in und auswendig ob bei bayern
müller spielt oder doch neuzugang
coutinho ist das wirklich spiel
entscheidend ein geheimnis jedenfalls
soll es bleiben wie dass es am
wochenende ausgeht kann nicht unwichtig
auch nicht sagt natürlich war man sich
darüber gedanken aber es ist nicht so
dass ich die komplette art und weise und
bayern münchen endet die jubelposen von
werner und lewandowski den topscorern
sind sie schon sehr ähnlich das spiel
könnte genauso ausgeglichen werden und
das top spiel natürlich morgen abend
ganz ausführlich bei uns im aktuellen
sportstudio
und ich kann nur hoffen dass sie ein
freies wochenende vor sich haben es soll
nämlich sonnig und warm werden
allerdings ist abkühlung auch in sicht
gleich mehr beim wetter von özden terli
christian sievers freut sich auf sie um
10 im heute journal und die gesamte
heute redaktion wünscht ihnen ein
schönes wochenende hier sind morgen
wieder da wenn sie mögen
einen schönen abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ein umfangreiches
hoch das dehnt sich noch weiter aus und
erfasst auch deutschland und so steigen
die temperaturen in den nächsten tagen
noch etwas an aber das tief hier im
norden das schickt seine kaltfront und
ab sonntag kommen dann im norden neue
regenwolken auf und der kommenden woche
sinken die temperaturen wieder schauen
wir erstmal in die kommende nacht und da
wird es in der nordhälfte aufklaren nach
westen hin gibt es nebel im süden da
sind dichte wolken unterwegs und dort wo
die wolken fehlen gehen die temperaturen
ordentlich zurück bis auf 5 grad sinken
die werte im süden sind zweistellige
temperaturen vor allem im südwesten bis
14 grad
morgen gibt es viel sonne im westen
deutschlands im norden auch einige
kompaktere wolken aber die sonne scheint
ja immer wieder durch im süden starten
ja aus der nacht noch mit den kompakten
wolken und die temperaturen ja die
liegen in der nordosthälfte bei 17 bis
20 grad nach südwesten hin sind 27 grad
die nächsten tage am sonntag bis 29 grad
warm viel sonnenschein im süden und da
kommt schon die kompakten wolken von
norden her rein und dann gehen die
temperaturen langsam zurück vor allem im
norden montag nochmal bis 28 grad warm
und dienstag deutlich kühler
ein schöner abend